tras análisis e investigación en la
agencia reguladora de medicamentos
británicas así como los expertos médicos
y científicos que asesoran al gobierno
recomiendan que la vacuna oxford
astrazéneca desarrollada en este país no
sea aplicada a la población entre los 18
y los 30 años por la posibilidad muy
remota de desarrollar coágulos después
de recibir la primera dosis a esta
población se les ofrecerá entonces la
vacuna pzifer o moderna que a partir de
hoy empezó a ser aplicada aquí en el
reino unido- inicialmente en galés y a
mitad de abril en toda inglaterra los
expertos insisten en que todavía los
beneficios de esta vacuna astrazéneca
son muchísimo más altos y que estos
casos de coágulos son extremadamente
raros y todavía no se ha establecido
cuál puede ser la causa y así además lo
soportan las cifras de 20 millones de
personas que han sido vacunadas se han
reportado 79 casos de coágulos y 19
personas
muerto ahora el primer trabajo del
gobierno será recuperar la confianza de
las personas en la vacuna han dicho los
expertos que si ya recibieron la primera
dosis deben acudir a la segunda que no
deben tener el temor pero que en caso de
tener efectos secundarios como dolor
fuerte de cabeza o en el pecho o tener
morados en el cuerpo deben buscar
atención médica inmediata por supuesto
este anuncio crea un tipo de crisis en
los planes en el cronograma muy
ambicioso de boris johnson de haber
ofrecido la vacuna a toda la población
adulta sobre los 18 años antes de
finales de julio